- Have you ever listened to anybody
when you ask them what's their flaw?
It's the biggest fucking
humble brag of all time.
I'm such an expert
that sometimes I make my team struggle
to keep up with my awesomeness.
(upbeat music)
And so this portion is like with me.
So I think this is when
you need to get selfish.
Like you need to ask your question,
you don't have to worry
about everybody else.
What I've learned through
doing some of these
is a lot of themes matter.
Some are very close businesses,
things of that nature
but theoretically, a lot of
us are dealing with HR stuff
or growth stuff.
So I think you'll get a lot out.
I want to hedge to make sure
you're asking your question
as if it was just us
so you get your answer so--
- Well we're together on this
but I have a question we were discussing.
Over the years,
our first business, first and foremost,
is (mumbles).
That's what pays
everything, that's on top.
We've had it for 10 years.
We have three brokerages out in Arizona.
But we implemented Do the Work.
So we've had the coaching and consulting
but now, I guess is the question,
we've always been coaching our agents.
We have 135 that are in the brokerage.
We've always coached
them through business,
personal and everything.
So we've been part of their lives.
When we created Do the Work,
it started as the coaching
and consulting business
but this is the problem,
when agents come on board,
they're constantly marketing Do the Work,
so they're out there.
But now a lot of people
are kind of confused
what do you do?
Are you a coaching and consulting
or are you a brokerage?
Because agents market
Do the Work constantly
as an associate.
So when you log on to our pages,
it's kind of like, are they agents?
When you're marketing Do the Work
it's like an agency, a real estate agency
or coaching and consulting.
So it gets a little confusing,
we don't know how to separate things.
- Well, okay.
Are you worried about that?
- [Male] I guess we're not worried,
well I guess it's not really a problem.
- 'Cause it sounds like a UY/UX issue
more than anything else
meaning what runs through
my mind when I hear that
and as you can imagine,
my life can get quite confusing too.
We have all sorts of shit going on.
People are always confused,
there's a lot of people who think
I'm literally just a public speaker.
There's a lot of confusion.
I think the question becomes
if you're creating less confusion
with your core websites?
You could create a bar at the
top of both of your websites,
the agent part world and the
brand and consulting thing
that literally navigates
people to the proper place
if they're looking for one or the other.
I'm trying to figure out is,
so the energy is created,
the top of the funnel is created,
then they go somewhere and if they thought
they were going to coaching and consulting
but they're over here,
I think it just becomes a matter
of how much clarity do you want to create
on the two separate businesses websites?
And do you have two
separate business websites?
- [Male] Yes, yes we do.
- I mean you could on the main business,
the tried and true business,
have something at the top that says,
"Are you looking for
Do the Work Consulting?
"Click here."
That literally solves your problem.
- [Male] I think we're
overcomplicating thinking
that it has to be one or the other.
- [Female] Yeah 'cause
we have a lot going on
with Do the Work
and then we have so much material
that we want to grow Do the Work,
(mumbles) it's growing and it's there
and it's kind of running itself,
if you kind of want to say it that way.
We have a full staff and everything.
But now it's him and I with Do the Work,
we have so much material out there.
We've come out with merchandise
and so we want to start
selling that merchandise--
- This is a super common thing.
There's so many people
that start a business
and then get into a place of
whether it's burnout,
whether it's excitement
for the second baby--
- [Female] Yes, it is, it's exciting.
- 100%.
So I think here's what I would say.
First and foremost,
what you need to do
is not create a framework
that creates vulnerability
to the first business
emotionally, not financially.
Your employees that work for that company
will know if your energy's
skewing too much to number two.
That's what matters.
Not I landed and I'm confused.
You can fix that in a Google search
or an H bar that I just told you to make.
Got it?
That's your issue.
And it doesn't have to be an issue.
It's the issue that the cliche move
that people like you always create
which is you want to create the perception
that you're fully focused on number one
but you're actions are too
obvious to any normal human being
that you're excited about number two.
I say you own being
excited about number two
but you never make number
one feel compromised
because you create infrastructure,
including very simple moves,
no different than as simple as I told you
to create an H hello bar up top.
You could promote an internal
person to be president
and give them a little more autonomy.
There's things you could do.
And I think I've been at my worst
when I've tried to juggle too
many things in my own head
and I've become a much
better version of myself
by leaning all in to the clarity
on wherever the fuck I am
which is why I've overexaggerated
my entrepreneurship
because at some level,
everybody here's like,
well, he's an entrepreneur.
I literally say in front of
the whole company sometimes,
I'm like, you do know that
next Tuesday you may walk in
and I might change this entire thing
into a company that sells hot dogs?
And it's because it's true.
So I think that to me is what smells
in a way that doesn't have to be bad.
That's what you need to reconcile.
Like if you're trying
to create Life is Good,
don't worry, be happy
and coaching and consulting underneath it,
that's amazing.
It's highly profitable,
it's the new thing.
It's like I understand it
but you need to reconcile
the past in a fair way,
in whatever that may be.
But nobody's gonna get tricked.
And over time, that will
become your vulnerability.
And so making a video or
standing in front of the company
and being like, yep, we're 63% here
and 37% here and guess what?
Our 63 and our 37% over here
is gonna make this even better
and our 63 plus the, it's what I do.
Like VaynerMedia is the
beneficiary of Gary Vee becoming,
I'm giving money.
What the fuck is this?
I don't need VaynerMedia.
You'd all pay for me.
So I proved to Steve Ross
and my brother and myself
that me building Gary Vee
over the last four years
has benefited VaynerMedia.
Do you have any partners
in the first business?
- [Male] No, it's just us.
- Well guess what, you're set.
- [Female] And second business, just us.
- So guess what, you're set.
Nobody's gonna have to
sit there and be like,
oh fuck, they're gonna care more there
'cause they own 100 of
that and only 50, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Now you just have to create
a little more clarity
internally at business one.
- Yes.
- That's your vulnerability.
- Okay.
- Make sense?
- Yes.
- A lot?
- Yeah.
- Cool.
It's just, it is that,
it is always that
and there's people like me
who are able to have Wine Library
and one day when I'm not
the CEO of VaynerMedia,
still be evergreen
businesses that are awesome
and all that work you put in.
And then there's people
who lose the first one
out of trying to bullshit it.
- [Male] Yeah, that's true.
No, we've been there before
where we get distracted by another thing
just because we're so
bored with this company.
- You're entrepreneurs.
I'm bored right now.
- [Female] Yeah, you
say that it's constant,
we're constantly building new things
and we're just kind of
like, okay, how do we--
- Just be authentically you
and be smart about how,
this is why I build
relationships with people
because there may be a
point where you need to,
it's a win/win.
People get more opportunity
and you get to scratch your itches.
- [Male] Yeah.
What's going on?
- [Male] I guess really my
biggest struggle right now
is I guess falling apart
in comparative spot to you,
it's figuring where the gap is
to go off of stacking
and go on the offensive
when it's not a monetary number
and the monetary side is easy.
So if you're still stacking
for an offensive that's not here,
I'm in a similar mindset to you
where I don't want destruction but I do.
I'd like to wake up and
see that they made it
start the progressive progress in China
with tariffs and everything.
I don't like that,
I'm looking for the reverse
but it's because I'm in that zone.
And it's in a spot where,
everything I want to build currently
or have got off track on
entrepreneurial venture
is that I go into stuff that I can do
and it's about collecting the W flag.
The W flag I want
but when there's only one of you
and there's the time set,
it's the money and the ability
to stack darts and bullets
come really easy
but take away the time to be creative
and when you get into
hiring your weakness,
my weakness is hiring.
- Well good news,
I think that if your weakness is hiring,
it only means that you're
just a compassionate, good guy
because you haven't figured
out that it's about firing.
And you've heard this from me.
- [Male] My friends,
people who worked for me in the past
have been friends
and it's terrible because
I ask them to do things--
- I'll tell you how I
figured it out somewhat,
big exit packages.
- [Male] As far as what?
- I hate firing too because I feel bad
and I don't care about money.
So that put me in a shitty spot
'cause I could make it, just like you.
If you could make money,
you never value the
thing that comes to you.
So somewhere along the line
based on how big my ambitions are
and I'm running pretty big companies,
I just realized, oh okay,
I'm just better off firing
somebody three months in
and giving them four months severance
than just sitting--
- I do it now.
Even if a person's worked
for me for six years,
he's come and gone
multiple times for 20 years
but if there's an opportunity
where he can make more money
than the job I'm providing,
I tell him to quit
like that's crazy--
- That's my dream
but that doesn't work either.
- [Male] Simple like,
hey, what do you think
about next Thursday?
I know we had a day
but this company wants
to pay me 2,000 bucks
to come do a shoot for
photography which is his passion.
I'll sit here and say,
yeah, don't worry about it
and then I'll put the load back on myself
without hiring the person
that could actually take care of that.
- It all depends on what,
it depends on your ego and
control and insecurities
and how you feel about
the people you hire.
To me, hiring--
- It's structure.
It's structure when
you haven't learned it.
It's the same way that
like high school's bullshit
because they don't teach
you how to write a check,
they don't teach you how
to balance checkbooks,
bullshit classes.
It's the flip.
- I get it.
- It's the process of it,
reading from a book that
was written three years ago
on how to do something
in an area I work in,
it's a worthless book.
- Look, if you're looking to hire a COO
or an operator or the
black and white person,
I think you just hire
and fire in perpetuity.
- [Male] You say hire
like the pool's an easy spot to find.
The process is the hard part.
The recruitment process I think is where
a lot of it comes down too.
- Not if you overpay.
- [Male] Huh?
Finding somebody who can operate anything
is stunningly easy.
I don't know what mental roadblock
is in your head right now
that makes you think you can't find them
or the pool's hard.
It's easy because you go and watch,
you go take it from somewhere
where they're already are doing it.
- [Male] But there's
certain things you can't,
there's certain things, instinctively
you can't turnkey the same way.
There's certain parts of my business
that I can't let go
which is what I'm not able to do.
- You don't give that to that person.
- [Male] Sure but that's
the core of the stacking
to go on the offensive.
- So then you eat shit and you stack.
- [Male] I get it.
It's being stuck in that spot.
- I'll give you an example.
I know exactly what you're saying.
I've given up a ton of money
over the last 36 months at VaynerMedia
to create the operational infrastructure.
I gave up new business.
We haven't sold anything for two years.
- [Male] Sure.
I'm with you that I'm
at the spot right now
where I do look at it as darts--
- But real quick, just to use,
it's what helped me get to
be able to work with now
in a way that's about
to be so transformative.
We've been for six
years doing buck, bucks.
If this year goes the way
I think it's going to,
I don't even want to dream,
outside of their own macro,
where the companies sell
and activists, investors
and what are they up to,
which is what sucks about client services
compared to starting a
business that you control
like retail or things of that nature.
But yeah, I mean look,
I think I totally understand that.
I understand exactly what you're saying.
Here's the problem,
continuing to stack
and the world doesn't collapse
for another 34 months,
you'd be like, fuck, I should've hired
the operational thing.
- [Male] Sure but what if
the plays not totally there.
That's my thing,
like spaces are opening.
We're in a similar spot,
like the weed space is opening,
it's a good space between
influencing music, rappers,
and everything like this.
- I agree.
- [Male] Everything I've done in the past,
they open themselves
but at this point,
the only satisfying thing
outside of fun,
what's called a W flag
in the smallest thing
like going and crushing Logical,
you're not doing the garage
sale thing for money.
- Yeah of course.
- [Male] To really enjoy the act of that,
like the same thing,
do I want to go find lemonade stands
and teach kids how to really
(crosstalk) 'cause it'd be fun?
Yes, absolutely.
The point is where's the long term value
when you don't have that play?
It was always to stack to
put everybody in a position
but then I put everybody
else in a position
and I don't want to do it to myself.
I think that's the flip.
I still live in the same house
I had before all this
because if I move to that next house,
I'm changing my position,
it's the underdog position.
But it's finding that spot to attack
when you've really been playing passive--
- I think that makes a ton of sense to me.
Here's what I can tell you.
You will be a disproportionately
resentful person
if you overvalue the next at bat.
So I'm talking about this crash a lot
which is what you're referring to.
It's funny how much I've been thinking
about the next one.
So I've been laughing
'cause I'm like, fuck,
what if tomorrow, everything does melt?
What if tomorrow is Bear Stearns?
Am I exactly as ready
as I've been talking?
Yes, no.
You're young.
If you put everything on
I've eaten shit for 15 years
and now I've got to take advantage
of this next downturn,
for me it's like, sure,
but they'll be two downturns in 20 years
and how old are you right now?
- [Male] 36.
- Yeah I'm like dude, or you do it at 56.
I think you need to take
some of the pressure
off of nailing it perfectly on this one
because I'm definitely
doing that with myself.
- [Male] Yeah, fair enough.
It's not about stacking money,
the way on this one to
be anything irrelevant
but for what it is,
conversation I started with--
- Look, every time--
- [Male] If you're playing for the Jets,
the Jets win the Super Bowl,
you're not playing for the Jets anymore.
You're reworking what that plan is.
- Honestly, that's easy
meaning you have to,
it's about self awareness
of what makes you happy.
It's easy to find games to win.
You just change your mind
on what that game is.
If the Jets win back to back
Super Bowls in three years,
it'll be the Knicks
and then if KD signs here and
the Knicks win a championship,
then I'll be like, you know what,
I'm gonna build the greatest
K through 12 business schools
in America, 30 of them.
So that's on you.
Yeah, it's a shift.
- [Male] But I mean
it's also just playing--
- We have more time tonight
and I want to get to everybody
so I'mma do that.
Hey.
- [Male] Hi.
So yeah, like it's Spoke
commercial real estate
but I grew up in the restaurant business
13 with my dad.
- What's bringing you in value at all?
Excuse me, I apologize.
- [Male] Yeah, so totally
easy to explain right.
Being in Vegas, we're
a very inbound market.
So the majority of companies
are not headquartered in Vegas.
I want to work on the transactions,
I've either got to be in CB, JL or--
- 'Cause they're feeding it?
- [Male] They're feeding it, right.
So when I moved--
- That's it?
- [Male] Yeah, period.
- That's it.
- [Male] So when I moved over to,
I was working two jobs.
I was working at my dad's place
and then working
and I started college for five years
and realized that wasn't the right firm,
they weren't bringing it to the market.
So for five years,
I haven't focused on Vegas at all.
I've focused on out-of-state brokers.
So we market everybody
in New York, Chicago,
LA, San Francisco, et cetera
and it's been really successful,
seen about 300% year over
year growth until this year.
Pretty flat was last year.
So now I'm like, oh shit.
- Why do you think that happened?
- [Male] Well I think why it's happened
is because we don't go after
a lot of our own clients
where we've been more
focusing on going after
the brokers that control the clients.
- Right, you don't have the leverage.
- [Male] Right.
So I've had some aha moments
growing up in the restaurant,
for me, it's all about service.
So when I was a waiter,
I was averaging 25% tips, pretty good
and it's based off service.
And so I've always
implemented customer service,
the little details, into my business.
We made a deal up in Vegas
with a big national law firm
and a very sophisticated
client, if you will,
and she said,
I'm doing a deal in LA,
Dallas, New York and Vegas.
You need to teach all these other guys
how to service the client.
Aha moment.
We just got back from Irvine
with a client for 3,000 fee,
he literally emailed the
global president of the company
talking about the
service we're delivering.
So we want to be able
to bring that service
to anybody and everybody.
- Okay.
- [Male] What I love about what
we do on the tenant rep side
is my business is set out
to only provide value to the client.
I tell people, I make less
money the better I do my job
which I love
because now I can help
you hire that new employee
you didn't have dollars for
or get you those three
extra months of free rent--
- If you prove it, it's leverage.
It's what my agency's doing
in the marketing world.
- [Male] Yeah.
So for us, we are considered to be
in that higher tier of people
actively involved on social media
from a commercial real estate standpoint
but we're doing it with
no playbook, if you will.
So my goal here today
is to learn the recipe, right,
to learning how to cook the meal
versus just reading the recipe.
- I understand.
- [Male] And with that,
our end game is to be able
to get our message out
to a point where I'm doing
zero transactionary work.
We're starting to build a team
so we're hiring a COO for the team
and we're hiring a transactionary broker.
So we're client interface
but once a deal gets to a point
of having to negotiate it,
go through the process with the leases,
that's off my plate.
And we want to grow the brand
to where we're not in Vegas at all.
We just want people to know us
as the commercial real estate team,
if you need help in any market
and don't know who to call, you call us.
We'll be your single point of contact,
we'll be the client interface,
we'll make sure the
service delivery's there
while using the local market expert
to get you the best deal possible.
That's why we're here, right.
And so for me, it's really
just trying to understand
the method to the madness.
My partner and I have
very similar strengths
and very similar weaknesses.
So we're trying to figure it out.
- So real quick,
I just want to get some clarification.
- Referral.
- What's that?
- No, I get that
but that would mean
starting your own company
to sit on top of?
- [Male] To an extent, right--
- You'd have to.
- I'd have to, right--
- [Male] Unfortunately the thing,
I was on a panel at
our national conference
in Miami a couple months ago
and I'm talking in the room
about high performance teams,
I'm like, guys, we're just starting
to be a high performance team
and how we got here was
through branding and marketing.
Let me tell all of you that work for,
they're not spending a dollar
on any of you in branding.
And our CMO was in the room
and she sat me down and
gave me this whole schpeal,
I'm like, but it's the truth
and the more we brand ourselves,
the more that brands the company value
from a social standpoint--
- Yeah but they don't want that
'cause then you'll have leverage.
- [Male] Right.
So the question is--
- ESPN controls how much
air time sportscasters have.
You don't have the leverage.
The only leverage you have
is controlling your expenses
to let you leave to
start up your business.
- [Male] Yeah which is kind
of where my head's at, right.
- So what I would do is I
would build your personal brand
with content at scale,
all the same shit you said on that panel,
on LinkedIn in perpetuity
while LinkedIn's unbelievably
organically strong,
keep building, keep building,
so that you wake up one morning
and after 47 emails came in that night,
I want you to work for
me, how do you work,
you just have that moment
where the practical, not the emotional,
the practical data's
staring you in the face
and you've been saving along the way,
same house, same house, along the way
and like, I live it.
I could've upgraded my
New York City apartment
for the last five years in a row.
I haven't 'cause I live
it, I believe in it.
And I'm happy.
I think the thought of
somebody controlling me
the way that they
control you is not happy.
- [Male] It's not, right
and until this year,
we were in the corporate shop,
we've always been under the flag.
And so previous ownership,
I'd always bring my issues like,
guys, this isn't how we
do it, this is bullshit.
They were just always setting up for sale.
They were like, we heard you, great.
- Yeah, that's cute.
- [Male] Right.
Now part of the big corporate flag
even harder to get what
we're trying to achieve.
- You'll never achieve it.
- [Male] Right.
- Nor should you,
it's not the game they're playing.
They don't care.
- [Male] Yeah, they don't.
- And they can't help it.
I have empathy for that global CEO.
He's like, that's fine
but I can't take the financial
hit to invest for 24 months
to change this organization's DNA
because if I'm down 13% year over year,
I'm gonna get fired by the board.
- [Male] Well especially
they just went public
so it makes it even tougher.
Yeah.
- You have to build your brand at scale,
I would recommend
LinkedIn content at scale.
- [Male] Yeah we do it.
- Like a lot.
You're basically,
every second that you're not putting
into building your brand's content
to give you leverage
to be able to leap and saving money
on whatever money you're making
and not spending money at home,
you'll be stuck, you're
in golden handcuffs.
You'll be stuck forever.
- [Male] Okay.
- Yeah, one of the things I'm trying to do
is now get people to
downgrade for happiness.
In real life scenarios
where I know more details,
I'm like trying to convince friends
to sell their home,
I'm like, you can leave tomorrow.
- [Male] I rent my house because of that,
I'd rather sit on the money in the bank--
- You need to find yourself a
year's worth of runway and go.
That's it.
- Cool.
- 'Cause you can always get a job again.
Fuck it, so you suck and you
weren't as good as you thought
and in month 10, you're like, fuck, I blow
and I'm going to be--
- [Male] I could open
a restaurant like that.
That's the easy play, right?
- Now, the economy can
collapse during that timing
and then all of it gets tougher but
that's just business.
- [Male] I started in
the recession, right,
so for me, recessions don't scare me.
- I agree.
One of the things that always scare me
about DTC products that
are so obvious right now
is like what happens?
Especially premium stuff, what happens?
It's just something
you have to go through.
That's why being overleveraged,
your first at bat is always scary to me.
It's where a lot of people get burned.
'Cause you never knew what it's like
when you get 337 orders
on Amazon every day
and then it's seven.
I had to refund $800,000
worth of wine in one hour
after Bear Stearns collapsed.
I never saw that.
- [Male] You're talking about that a lot.
Are you foreseeing something there?
Everyone's talking about it.
- I've been talking about
it for two fucking years.
I haven't been super right.
I guess I'm kind of right
'cause Amazon and Facebook and Netflix
are down a lot in stock
over the last six months.
It feels right
but honestly the reason
I'm talking about it
is 'cause the delusion
in the other direction's
accelerating even faster.
It's not that I think it's
gonna happen tomorrow,
it's just like, kids are like,
kids are committing suicide
'cause they overleveraged
their credit cards
to buy bitcoin
because it was gonna go to 100,000 a coin.
There needs to be a practical
voice in the ecosystem
that is at least charismatic enough
to maybe penetrate all these knuckleheads.
I feel a sense of responsibility
to not even kidding.
There's not a lot of
characters with sizzle like me
that can get through a
23 year old alpha guy
and be like, wait a minute,
maybe I should save my money
'cause everything else is like,
girls and champagne and Lamborginis.
They're completely being
sold to overexaggerate
which means overleverage
which means bad stuff.
The big fear I have right now
is that we've never had
this much public losses.
The last time the economy collapsed,
there wasn't a generation
of people with audiences
telling them
that they were the best
businessmen of all time
and then how to take a loss.
This one's gonna hurt emotionally
and I don't think a lot of kids
were built to take that kind of L.
So I'm worried.
- Especially when the egos
blow up so fast.
- And it's gonna be ugly,
it's gonna be bad.
It's gonna be bad.
What do you do?
You're Rolexing and flexing
and now you have to go work at a company
and you don't want to,
people are not gonna,
people are gonna lose
and then not want to get a job
to start the five year process to get back
'cause they don't want to
look bad on social media.
So what are you gonna do?
You're gonna triple down on bad behavior.
Shit's gonna get ugly.
So that's why, really.
That's what you need to do, bro.
- [Male] Yeah.
- The internet will squeeze everybody.
The internet is the middleman.
Everybody's industry will just,
it's just a moment in time,
either you're the book stores
and the limo drivers are caught now,
rocket mortgage, leopard
all this, giraffe,
the internet will take everything.
- [Male] So just kind of more going into
where is that space going
with voice related to that--
- I don't think voice
is your biggest issue.
Yes, do I think in nine years,
it's possible that I say, hey Alexa,
get me the best mortgage rate?
Yes, I think Amazon
will own that or Google
or whoever pays them a
fuckload to be the result.
If you're in the middle,
you are vulnerable in a 20 year window.
That's my official point.
The problem is if that's 17 years from now
when it gets real bad
where it really hurts,
well, how are you gonna play that?
Or is that four years from now?
That has to do with other entrepreneurs.
Book stores didn't have to be first.
That was Jeff Bezos's doing.
Limos didn't have to be next.
That was Travis's doing.
Personal brands are
super not pumped with me.
If you sell $400 ebooks right
now, I'm a problem, right?
There you go.
That's what's happening
and it's playing out in
front of everybody's eyes
because I'm also,
it's not just that I'm getting the market,
I'm inspiring the next
people for a different model.
I think it's in trouble
but I think that leads to opportunity.
But I think being eyes wide open,
I don't think we're buying
mortgages through Alexa
in the next five years
but in eight, maybe
and I think that something to think about.
I will.
'Cause I don't value anything else.
It's just data.
Certain things will still,
and listen, there's always
a market for high touch.
I think you go super
premium or super discount
and everything in the middle is garbage.
- [Male] That's hard.
The super premium route
of being (mumbles),
understanding money, how
your money works for you,
not just the mortgage consultant side,
it's the whole package of
where to put your money best
and how to make it work best.
- Yeah and so more, more.
To me, it's like, the internet's one
and the guy and the gal
that's willing to go the person's house,
pick them up out of bed,
sit them down, make
them a fresh juice drink
and then go through all their finances.
Got it?
That's who's gonna win.
That's the only people
that are gonna be around
in a 50 year window.
And it's kind of like every
industry, if you look at it,
plays that out.
I think the internet's
gonna make it more extreme.
I'd much rather own an
$18 bar direct-to-consumer
than a three dollar bar.
Harder but in my thesis, plays out better
if you're able to pull it off.
I'd rather get the tears
of a seal ingredient,
that's how I think about it.
It's why I did the wine that I just did.
If you look at direct-to-consumer,
if you look at what people are drinking,
it's a $40 rose for 20 bucks,
that's a premium rose.
That's what I would think about.
- [Male] So 30 seconds
of boring background
to get to the question.
We're the ones doing the stuff
and that's under this broader umbrella
of beam distributing.
So in a lot of cases
for the cooler business
which has done pretty darn well for us,
we are sort of, if I were
to make it overly simple
like a partner on bringing
products to market
and getting them out that also sells them.
But we are technically a separate entity.
So I guess where my question goes,
and this is one that
we've pontificated over
a couple of belts at the hotel bar
is does it make sense to
start growing something
that is completely
agnostic to another brand
that at the end of the day,
has say and control over what we do?
- Of course.
This is all about leverage, the end.
It just is, it just is.
Whoever has the leverage,
will milk the provider
for when they need them
and as soon as they don't, they won't.
Now you may say, well we make it better
or we do this better, until you don't.
There could be a day when that happens.
Other entrepreneurs or your
own ambitions or needs.
Being at the mercy of anything
is a bad business eventually.
It just is.
But building a brand
is not as easy as it sounds.
That's why people are
willing to be at the mercy
of Adidas and Nike and, you know?
- [Male] A little bit
extra nuance on that.
We've gotten pretty good
at the marketing machine
of make more dollars than what we--
- Is the first part you said, I apologize,
is the first part a B to B business?
- [Male] We're split into thirds.
The overall company is,
it's a third direct-to-consumer,
third government contract,
third B to B company.
- So it's two-thirds B to B in theory?
- [Male] Yeah.
Government contract is
such a unique business,
I wouldn't--
- Respect.
But a third of your business is consumer
and that business is a website that sells?
- [Male] Coolers.
- All coolers?
- [Male] Just.
- Just, right.
That's shit.
You're gonna have to
do something about that
meaning it's shit at the most macro.
It might be phenomenal,
it's great, it's a good brand,
you're better at marketing than they are
so you have some leverage right now
but you're not because they
make one higher and you're not.
Your leverage can't be you're better
at CAC and LTV than they are.
- [Male] What's CAC?
- Cost of customer,
customer acquisition cost.
If you're better at selling
coolers than they are
on their separate website
'cause you're better at CAC than they are,
that's a bad, bad place to be in.
'Cause they can just hire VaynerMedia
and I'll beat you next year.
And then you have no leverage
or the same leverage you had
and so then they can
start dicking you around,
whatever that may,
I don't know enough details yet,
exclusive contracts,
how do they compensate you.
They will 100% eventually
only sell it themselves.
You're doing the dirty work for them
to build up the leverage.
They have to.
- [Male] They've already started.
- Go figure.
- [Male] How do you feel about,
since we know that space
much better than jumping
into something at random,
doing something similar
versus picking a market
that we think makes sense or just--
- Similar.
Well can you?
In a dream world, we're
making rhinoceros and going,
whatever said,
I would literally Google
what animal kills the most
and start that brand,
literally, literally that's
what I would do, literally.
Literally I would create,
I literally would create shark---
- [Male] I like that.
- I would start that.
Now the question becomes can you
based on the deal you have with them?
Even if it wasn't in a contract,
as soon as you show that look
what does that mean?
How much revenue is that driving for you?
Are you willing to go to,
everything to me is zero,
the fact that I'm so crazy
that I'm willing to
walk outside right now,
leave this whole thing
at start at zero again
like I did this thing
is why all my partners
treat me the way that I do
because they know it to be true.
That's the best.
Leverage.
So do you have the leverage?
To me, what's cool
is you have two-thirds of other business.
So to me it's like,
if you know the inevitable,
to me it's like go on the
offense versus the defense.
The best case is the advice I gave him
which is can you establish
Walrus Coolers now
and not create conflict with?
Can you be cute for two years?
Yeah, we'll jump.
We'll get to everybody.
- [Male] And that has a lot to do
with the question that I was gonna have.
We accept the inevitable
that it will eventually
all be direct from them,
whether that's a five or 10 year window,
but the transition from now until then,
my question is aside
from just sheer volume,
how can we increase the
leverage we have over them?
- Starting a separate brand.
You are so wrong about that brother.
The leverage is not
gonna be your leverage.
The volume is not gonna be your leverage.
- [Male] No, no, no, no, no, no.
- It's just not.
It's actually will speed up
the process of them leaving.
- [Male] Oh, 'cause they see
their leverage shrinking?
- Not even that.
Guys, when you own the brand
and use a third party vendor,
I don't know enough
but if we were over a five hour dinner
or if I was your cousin,
I'd be like, bro, what
if they get funding?
What if they do a cash infusion?
What if somebody buys the company
who's a DR?
There is no five to 10 years.
It could be tomorrow.
Outside of me not knowing the contract.
- [Male] Sure, sure and you're right,
it could be tomorrow.
So I guess the impetus of the question is
how do we ease that
transition for ourselves?
- By starting the process
of building the brand.
You'll notice,
and I think this is so much of my success,
even when I don't like what's
going through my own head
for myself,
it's always binary.
The answer is super binary.
What happens is you get golden handcuffs
and you start trying
to justify to yourself
why it's not gonna happen.
You're spending all
your time in the shower,
in your bed, brushing your
teeth, walking down the street,
justifying why it's gonna
be four years, not one year
'cause you like what you're getting.
I hate that.
That to me is anxiety.
I'd rather,
I'd rather cut bait and bounce
than to have something
like that sit over my head.
Thus, since I don't
think you could cut bait
and just cancel, shut down the company,
you should create Walrus
and if Walrus starts
doing anything of any kind
that gets them bothered, they're like,
you better stop Walrus or,
you'll be like, you gotta go.
You got to basically cut it off
and then kind of hope
that it takes longer for them.
That is the only anecdote
to create leverage
in the third party seller environment.
- [Male] Makes sense.
- It's 100%.
- [Male] Thanks for the honesty.
- And a lot of people lose
in this scenario, a lot.
- [Male] Because they're
not willing to cut?
- Yeah 'cause they're
doing what you're doing
which I have empathy for.
I don't think it's,
I don't think it's wrong as a human.
It's 100% wrong as a business.
You don't have the leverage.
And the world is,
the other thing you have to layer
is the macro world.
The world is going more DTC.
You know how pumped these guys are
that they're not them?
She's worried about Walmart and Costco.
They have all the
leverage, all the leverage.
These guys are like, oh
Shopify, Amazon, nothing.
Their problem is that like
these two fucking characters
every single person's
going to their fucking bar
and go direct-to-consumer.
So it's a huge opportunity
but everybody's in it.
When she was selling,
being in the business in
America in 1999 or 2006
was impossible.
You need a drillion dollars
just to make it, just to get into fucking,
you know how much money it
costs to get into Costco
or Walmart?
Now it's game over, man.
It's all going.
The internet will eat everything,
including the media,
including retail, all of it.
- [Male] So yeah my
bars are six cellar bars
so I play a little bit in
the higher price space.
100% direct-to-consumer,
actively turning down retailers.
The insight I'm hoping to glean
is about half of our
revenue's from Shopify,
half is from sales funnels, click funnels.
Having seen you speak at click funnels,
know some of those guys,
they're really preaching
that click funnels
are like the new website.
I want to get your insights as far as--
- I want to make sure I
understand the full clarity
of click funnels
'cause obviously I've spoken there.
I understand the theme
but I want to understand.
Break down the whole click,
because it sounds like somebody
else is gonna have leverage.
- [Male] So I don't think
someone else has leverage
but using a sales funnel
instead of a website.
So how they would describe
it is a website is a static
versus using a proven sales funnel.
- I would say both.
Because what click
funnels do at their best
is give you great sales
but fuck your brand
'cause it looks like shit,
even if you make it good.
What a website does is it can look great.
So your website can have that anchor video
that's your Dollar Shave Club video
and you can get the brand across.
I kind of look at click
funnels theoretically
as things like outlet stores
or shipping it to other countries.
It's a way to move inventory
but you don't necessarily want your brand
directly associated with it,
especially when you're selling
a six dollar fucking product.
If it doesn't feel the part
as much as a six dollar product,
there's a reason that (mumbles) website
looks the way it does.
Everybody in that world
in the Idaho offsite keynote,
they all care about sales.
There's a very specific
reason I am who I am.
I'm brand.
The end.
There's a lot of people that sell
$49 million worth of tee shirts in sales
but they're not polo.
- [Male] Sorry what's a click funnel?
- It's landing page optimization at scale.
It's like theoretical
psychological arbitrage.
If you look at,
he's got multiple sites that when you land
just does a better job
of getting you to buy the fucking product.
It's got really dirty DNA from
early internet marketing shit
but to the credit,
it's evolving to being more clean
thus it's trying to find that,
it's kind of me.
Listen, at some level,
I'm really good at sales and branding
and that's why having tension between both
is why I'm able to be successful.
I do think that you are
giving up brand because,
look, first impressions matter.
I don't know what else to say.
Are you gonna marry the
person that you hook up with
at 3:30 in the morning in a Vegas club?
Maybe but it's a different
context of meeting that person
than if you met at a coffee shop,
it's just different.
They're both ROI positive,
there's other things
but I do think it matters,
I do think it matters.
And that's how I think about brand.
- [Male] That's why I
wanted to ask the question
is following that community,
I feel I can definitely do get sucked in
where a lot of them would say--
- I know what they would say.
- [Male] By sending
traffic to your website--
- You're throwing money
away in the long term
is how I look at it
which is why most of those people
become cryptocurrency
experts six years later.
Got it?
There's always chasing fast bucks.
Finding the balance, though,
because that's my DNA understands that
and then just obviously,
what's the open timing?
- Can I just see your phone?
- Gotta do something, sorry about that.
- What's up with timing?
I got 20 or yeah?
And then I can push it a little bit.
Yeah, okay.
It's the reverse in brand land.
They're so in outer space on brand,
there's no level of
practicality, not to pick on,
macro, macro,
they're so like let's do a TV commercial
and buy a billboard and just
brand and not practical.
So they're too far there.
The world that you're talking
about is too far there.
That's why I think my spot
has been so good for me.
But I will always lean closer to her
than that world.
I will never sacrifice brand, ugh.
I turned down an eight
million dollar check
to go to China for 30
minutes and film a video
but I knew it was for a
network marketing product
that was full of shit
and I wasn't willing to give
up my brand in China for it.
It's hard to pass up on an
eight million dollar paycheck
for 30 minutes.
It takes discipline.
This was like four years ago too
when it was less obvious that China,
I was less of a global mindset.
Like well, it's China.
George Clooney does that shit.
Brad Pitt, they love going
to Japan and do a commercial
but you don't see it here.
I'm like, that's smart.
You know?
It depends on what you're trying,
now again, and this is
what I kind of started with
when I jumped in
inappropriately on Antonia
'cause I got excited about the question,
if you think a private equity firm's
on the verge of buying you
and you're like, mmm,
I'm gonna take a blast
of like 10 more million in profit,
you always have to
contextualize these answers.
But yes, that's the answer.
- [Male] My question is I'm
in a little bit different spot
than (mumbles).
We're closing the final
sale of a start up.
- Number two, you said?
- [Male] Yeah, second start up.
And gonna try and go a
different route this time
and looking at more just
consulting, helping people,
kind of build tech companies.
We read a lot of books, radical
candor, things like that,
it doesn't really apply with
Google, they did it this way,
but it doesn't really work.
So trying to move into that space.
So I've been really writing a lot, a book,
and I guess my question is,
do you see any downside to self publish
versus going trying to find a publisher?
- Yeah, I think self publishing
has less brand equity.
- [Male] Okay.
- I'd rather give up the economics
which I do.
I always say watch what
I do, not what I say.
I don't self publish.
I have all the leverage.
Harper Collins sells zero
books when I sell them,
it's all me.
Why am I willing to give
up 50 cents on the dollar?
Because the brand association
with self publishing
is not as good as with publishing.
It's gotten way better a
decade later than it was.
20, 15 years ago,
we were making some eye contact with this,
15 years ago it was for
the scum of the scum.
It's way better, it's
way better, way better.
Listening to your narrative,
back to contextual,
if you're trying to make that leap
to have brand equity to leverage,
I think it would help you
to get a bullshit $10,000
advance from Simon and Schuster
to have that versus self
publishing, in my opinion.
Hot takes matter.
And a hot take on you, quick read on you
first time I hear of you
'cause you wrote a good Medium piece
and your book is Simon and Schuster
versus self publishing,
it will matter, I think
for what your actual goal is
which is to leverage that
to do some consulting,
get some equity, right?
- [Male] Yep.
- Look, this is a funny thing to say,
every piece of my behavior
is based on that advice.
I'm basically trying to
be the best person ever
to every entrepreneur
just in case I fall short eventually
in 23 years for the Jets
and I can rally 50,000 people
to give me $150,000 each
like I'm not even kidding.
- The barter would be for real.
- Yeah like when I kickstart
the entire Jets process,
people are gonna be like,
how the fuck did it happen?
It was gonna be 31 years of work
where I brought more value than I took.
Otherwise, I'd be taking
like a mother fucker.
I'd be making $50 million a year
just being Gary Vee and being
on an island mastermind,
fucking $400,000 a head.
All those fuckers make fun of me.
They make fun of me behind
their back all the time.
That's what they tell the kids,
he's stupid, he doesn't make
as much money as he should
'cause they're playing
short, I'm playing long.
A sprinter thinks a
marathon runner's stupid,
they lost the race, right?
Life is long.
Life is fucking long,
that's where everybody got confused.
Life is long.
That's why I want people
to cut their costs down
because if you can make it through
the recession that's coming
whenever it comes,
three years from now, tomorrow,
you'll be in a really nice spot
but do you love what you sell?
Do you love what you do?
'Cause that's the only way you
can get through those years.
'Cause if you're in it
for the money, right,
I don't know you guys
but if it's like, oh shit,
there's this Expo West
and I'm gonna go there,
I'm gonna and buy it in three years
and I'm just gonna arbitrage the internet
and flip it and be like
fucking Dollar Shave Club,
well then that's not
the game you're playing.
There's absolutely
nothing wrong with that.
You just have to know
what game you're playing
and you can't be full of shit to yourself.
Back to the cooler thing.
Can't be full of,
the only vulnerability in business
is when you're bullshitting yourself
out of what you hope is gonna happen
versus what's actually happening.
And that's why I've been good
'cause I'm pivoting all the time.
I've got hopes and dreams
of how it would play out too, every day
but I don't navigate in
anything but the reality.
So yeah, I think to be very frank,
I don't think a book carries
that much weight altogether.
I'd much rather you start a podcast
that you're doing weekly
and writing on LinkedIn and
putting out white papers
and just fucking going.
- [Male] Okay.
- I like the book though, I like it,
I just want to make sure
that you don't overvalue it
'cause it doesn't carry anywhere close
to the weight it used to.
- [Male] Right along those lines--
- No, no, you're fine.
- [Male] Monopolize.
If say we go the LinkedIn route,
more or less then convert
those into chapters,
is that a concept?
- I'm not against that.
Let's go very macro.
Put out as much of your
best advice as possible
for as low cost as possible
and a lot of good things will happen.
It just will.
'Cause you're competing
against a lot of content.
So you want to create the
least amount of friction.
That's why I make my content in all forms.
You like listening while you run?
I'm here for you.
You like reading?
Good.
You like watching videos?
Surely got that covered.
You want micro videos?
Yep, got it.
Look at the lack of friction I create.
I've got every format of consumption
and I've got every distribution channel.
While everybody else is getting sucked
into just being on Instagram.
Instagram's gonna be MySpace one day,
it happens to everybody.
So got it?
And then I talk a lot
about self awareness.
So are you a better writer?
Are you good on video?
Are you weird on video
but you're good on audio?
Figure out how you communicate
to the world and do that.
I'm always worried that
people try to be like me.
The only way people should be like me
is they should be self aware.
- [Male] So I guess it starts
off in the transition period.
Sold most of my retail stores now,
I have one left.
So I'm really focused in on building
my nutrition lines now.
We're currently doing 80%
wholesale and subscription box
and then 20% direct-to-consumer,
Shopify and Amazon.
I'm trying to make that shift
and really make it a
direct-to-consumer brand
and I'm actually kind of
had a little bit of hangover
from retail.
So now it's like finally
I'm ready to build
this organization around it
and kind of looking for the next steps
on who to bring on.
I've outsourced everything
up to this point,
I'm a one man show.
- Math and art.
You're only in the math and art business.
So it's just the cadence
of how you want to figure
out your math and art.
I'd like to have one of
each to start though.
That's all this is.
This whole fucking thing
is one big game of math and art
equally respecting itself.
- [Male] Okay.
And then the plan is to kind of develop
into the nutrition
business is pretty shady,
there's a lot of shady characters in it.
So my idea and to help
build my personal brand too
is to create a line extension
that's essentially, to take
from the wine business,
single vineyard kind of supplements.
So basically from farm to bottle
and track that process,
shed full light on it.
- Super smart.
It's what I did with the wine project.
We literally filmed everything.
I have a year and a half
from the first meeting,
we decided to do it
to like being at the farm, all that shit.
That will work.
Transparency will work.
- [Male] I mean that's
what the industry needs.
- 100,000%.
- [Male] It's crazy.
It scares me how crazy it is.
- Oh I mean I hate the industry.
I'm scared shitless of it.
The amount of people private labeling
shit they have no idea
what the fuck's in it
and pushing it.
Who the fuck knows what's
gonna happen with people?
- [Male] Yeah and that's one
of the reasons why I want to--
- I couldn't agree with you more.
I hate motivational
speakers and personal brands
which is why I do it.
I hate agencies.
You can't imagine what I feel
about the partners of big companies.
The people that think
they're the establishment
and I'm the snake oil salesman
because they're ripping people off.
So I get it.
Actions, just like the last
question, actions always win.
- [Male] Okay.
And the stepping from
nutrition, powders and pills
into doing more beverage,
any advice on how to create
almost separate brand identity,
keep it all together?
- I think both can work.
I think it's how healthy is the
first brand identity, right.
- [Male] Yeah, got it.
- And so if you're looking to do it sooner
and that one's not established
the way you want, then I'd go separate.
- [Male] Okay, okay.
- A lot of brands have
started other things
that haven't worked.
They cut bait and it doesn't
affect the mothership.
- [Male] Okay.
- [Female] I'm gonna let him take.
Yeah go for it.
- You got it.
- Alright, I'll go first.
So it's really interesting.
I'm getting a massive amount
of perspective as I go on
'cause I'm a bootstrap entrepreneur.
I go to my kitchen slowly growing
and it's been a fun process
but it's like funny that
the further I get in
the more I realize, I don't know,
I don't have experience doing this stuff.
And that's been cool
because it's been a
slow, steady long road,
figure it out as we go,
make tons of mistakes,
get a lot better.
So that's been really good.
I'm like pumped with our success.
And as you probably know
when I got in the keto game,
no one was in the keto game.
I wasn't the only bar,
I was the only product.
- Why'd you get into it so early?
- Because I lost 70 pounds
right out of college
by going on it.
- Wow.
And how'd you stumble on it, the internet?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Reddit.
So like I started by literally
on the keto subreddit,
that's where I started,
those are my people.
So the crazy thing is
this journey's been all fun and games
and again way beyond what I ever expected.
Then 2018 comes
and now everyone knows what keto is.
It's blowing up.
And it's weird because it's taken us years
to figure out how to make
a really shelf stable bar
whereas when you show up with $10 million
to a contract manufacturer,
you get that shelf stable bar on day one.
And like that's not where we came from.
- That's right.
- So the weird thing for me
is like now is this incredible
blowing up opportunity
and we are getting a lot
of the benefits of that.
But there's a million other
people coming in the game.
Our product's better,
we have OG status,
we have the name.
We have a lot of things
that are going for us
but like we're still feeling the heat,
we're feeling the pressure.
And I guess what my
question is or my feeling is
my like we'll just figure it out as we go
and get better along the way status
is going away.
- Is getting suffocated.
- It's getting suffocated.
Our FOMO is like whoa.
All these influencers that
we have relationships with
that were OGs,
well now there's 10,000 new ones
'cause they all just found
the diet in this past year.
So as someone that's realizing
that I don't know everything
and that I also want to take advantage
of the opportunity that's available--
- It all depends on how
you're thinking about it.
- I want to do the best I can.
That's my job.
- My personal point of view
then, one man's point of view
is you stay in perpetuity then.
- What do you mean by that?
- You go through the
beating you're about to take
and you come out the
other side because that's,
the cliche thing that 98%
of the people like you do
which is hire the president
that used to work at Kellogg's
to run the business
but she or he is used more to
than being a small brand,
they lose every time
and I mean every time.
- And that's kind of the game we're--
- And everyone's spook,
yeah, of course, everyone's spooking you.
- Give away power
and to just go pick up some dude.
So a good example is we literally
have been talking about a guy
that used to work with
and alright, so now we
worked out a retainer,
he's gonna help us out
and even that I'm like,
man, I gotta take this
guy's word for some stuff
'cause he's been in the
industry longer than me,
I can't vet him,
how do I vet him?
- And you're gonna lose nine
out of 10 of those times.
- So you just don't
look vulnerable to them?
Take as much help as you can get
but don't make yourself vulnerable?
- Yes.
There's been one long two
hours of keep the leverage,
leverage is everything.
Yes, I love you being on a retainer
versus, people give up
pieces of their company
- Yeah, which I'm not
interested in in any situation.
- And by the way, maybe you will
after he crushes it for six
months and you love him.
But look, even that,
that was a smarter decision
than nine out of 10 people make.
Look, I always believe that people
that go with their
natural instincts are bet,
do you know how many people told you
to give 10%, 15% of your company up
to somebody who,
it's the advice you get
from people all the time.
People that have never been through it.
This is why I have no time
for MBAs and professors.
I just don't want to take advice
from anybody whose never done it.
Everything's cute in the book.
- So what's your advice then for me?
I want to ramp up my speed a little bit.
I don't want to give up leverage,
so I still own 100% of the company myself
but I don't want to miss
out on the whole thing, too,
I don't want to get smoked.
Like you just do the best
you can, gut instinct--
- You can take debt.
You want to take debt?
- No.
- Cool.
You can give a piece of your equity--
- [Male] No.
- Then you need to go slow.
- [Male] Yeah, okay.
- If you want cash,
you're not saying anything other than
I might need some cash to
accelerate my business.
- [Male] That's weird too
'cause I'm a saver
so we have a bunch of cash,
now I'm protective of it
'cause it took us four and
a half years to get it.
So we're doing some things and I'm like,
okay, well I can write a big check,
but I only want to
write one or two of 'em.
- Here's my thing.
It's highly likely
that this will be a tough chapter
but how long do you want to do this?
- Yeah, I don't know.
- Well that's a very fair answer
and that is the question.
- It's fun, it's fun
so I don't want to stop--
- Until it's not
after 18 months of
getting your face beat in.
- I always say to people,
this is a roller coaster
I don't want to get off,
this is exciting right now.
- Look, all these things
are about options.
Everything has trade-offs.
Look, I think that
direct-to-consumer capabilities
of CBG products
are gonna grow exponentially
over the next 20 years.
So even though you're gonna
have a lot more competition,
a lot more people are gonna
buy bars on the internet
and not at 7-Eleven and Kroger's.
So it just depends on
the supply and demand
of the competitive set.
Your competition's gonna grow
but if the demand of bars on the internet
or keto grows enough,
you won't feel the pain.
It all just depends on that.
- Yeah, okay.
- There's too many variables
outside of this conversation
that will play out.
I think this is why I keep pushing,
what are you up to?
He's up to selling businesses.
He's done it twice now.
That's what he was about.
I never want to sell Vayner ever.
I want to use it for everything else I do.
They're in the process
of having a second meaningful business
and that's what they want to focus on
'cause it's exciting, it's different.
It really, really, really
matters where you are.
You're so young.
So for me, when you're so young,
I think it's great to,
I think every kid should
get their ass kicked once
'cause then it doesn't make you scared
of getting your ass kicked.
So I like telling young entrepreneurs
to just keep going
even if the company goes out of business
and they come here and
say, you're a fucker.
I'm like, yeah, I'm a fucker
but you're 29 now
and you've been on both sides of it
which means you have pattern recognition
which means when you start
your next thing next year
at 31 after a year of maybe getting a job
and just getting back on your feet,
and if you're a saver,
that means you're not gonna go into debt,
you're gonna just lose upside.
- Right, this is
definitely an upside play.
We're not gonna go out of business.
We're not gonna lose our email list.
We're not gonna lose our
faithful customers, our following
but there's some FOMO.
- The only thing you're not
gonna lose is your brand.
You can lose all three of
the things you just mentioned
if people stop opening emails
at any kind of significant level,
if the ads on Facebook get too expensive
'cause organic's going
in only one direction,
that's just the flight of the game.
That's why I want people in
here to do LinkedIn right now
'cause LinkedIn organic is
very good and it won't be.
You're always going to
where organic's best.
When everyone was crying
about their Facebook page
organic three years ago,
I was pumped 'cause it reset.
Made it harder again.
- Real quick.
I was overshadowed by her question,
I had a separate question over here.
- [Female] Yeah, you skipped him.
- What's that?
Let me finish this off.
I'll be right there.
- [Female] There's three or four of us
and we've been doing it for awhile.
We're smart, we're good at a lot of things
but I wouldn't say any of
us are experts at anything.
So we do want to hire
more people, we need to.
I'm trying to think what expert,
what SEO, video, Amazon,
what's the first one we should focus on?
We're not gonna get all the people--
- Yeah, we're just a bunch of grinders.
We don't know anything.
- Sure you do, you know everything.
I'm just a grinder too.
- The first 10 here versus--
- Yeah, the first 30
people we hired here--
- [Female] What do you need?
- Should we (mumbles)?
- What do you want?
You need what you want.
What do you want first?
You want to be better at Amazon?
Well you need somebody
that's great at Amazon.
- [Female] Someone really creative and fun
and analytics and the
tracking, all of that
is like I think we need someone--
- Good, you need somebody hardcore math.
- [Female] Math, yeah,
that's what I think.
- We're gonna take one
of your guys--
- Fine, we've got a ton,
we've got a lot of 'em.
Reading, Pennsylvania's a
nice place to live, too.
I think you need math.
- [Female] I agree.
I think so too.
- But here's the thing,
everybody thinks these,
running a business is not like getting,
and even marriage, you
can get a divorce, what?
Cool, you hired math Matt
and you thought he was gonna be the best.
He went to fucking MIT and
he's gonna be the greatest.
You found out he's sexual predator,
you've got to fire him.
I don't understand how everybody thinks
they're gonna make these decisions
that in perpetuity are gonna be perfect.
I basically go the other way.
I think every decision I
make is a fucking mistake
and then if something works
out, it's a happy upside.
I'm being dead fucking
serious, by the way.
That's why I don't judge
or try to be overperfect.
I make decisions.
I value the speed of the decision
over the right decision
because I can fucking
fix the wrong decision.
That's why I've been able to
build big businesses fast.
- [Male] Just go.
- What?
What do you think,
you think somebody who gives
you a resume in interviews,
that's the most PR'ed
version of themselves
in the history of life.
Do you know what
everybody's biggest flaw is?
They work too hard.
Sometimes I'm so passionate
about being great,
I can work too hard and burn myself out.
Get the fuck out of here.
Right?
Have you ever listened to anybody
when you ask them what's their flaw?
It's the biggest fucking
humble brag of all time.
I'm such an expert
that sometimes I make my
team struggle to keep up
with my awesomeness.
Fuck you.
I think everything's a mistake.
I'm thrilled when it's worked out.
And once it actually is a
mistake, I make a change.
That's why it works.
- Alright, so we run podcasts, lives
and we have two editors.
He's one of them there.
What would be some of the responsibilities
that we should give our minimum standard
for a company our size
to be able to make sure
that we're constantly just
feeding the different mediums?
Obviously, we have our own personal brands
and then the two companies.
What do you think would be
a good strategy for them
or will it be the next hire?
- Well I think you need
to produce as much content as possible.
I think volume is the
breakthrough concept.
To the point where between
what I'm talking about,
between what I'm doing with clients,
I've been kind of like fuck,
what's gonna be my next book
and literally I might
write a book called volume.
That's how much I believe in it.
- Okay.
- So the answer to your question
is as much as you can humanly afford.
Nothing you're about to say is no
if you can afford it.
- Yeah.
- [Male] Can I kind of off that note?
- [Male] So like he said,
I'm editor
and then we have one back in Arizona
and we find that yes, I agree with you,
volume is a huge thing
but I feel like we create more content
videowise and everything
than we have time to edit
and then on top of that,
I also have other responsibilities
aside from just video editing
and creating graphics,
I also do the podcast recording,
I manage our websites,
I manage our social media.
- Makes sense.
Comes down to a very simple thing.
- [Male] And then I
also do for associates,
I take what is it, the
card orders, sign orders,
things like that.
- No, no, it's not at all.
I hear this every day.
- [Female] Should we just fire him?
- No, no, I think it's
actually very simple.
I'm like that's cool and as you should
if they want to produce
that level of content.
You're a human,
they've got an allocation of dollars
and if they want to, that makes sense,
seems like a nice solid workload
and clearly if Karen was also here
and she did half of that stuff
or a third of it or two-thirds of it,
you would have more output.
There's a reason my team
went from three people to 20 people.
I wanted dramatically more output.
I also wanted to train people
to put into the VaynerX machine.
I don't need 22,
I need probably seven.
I'm doing 22 so I can keep training people
so they can work,
so day two can be successful on.
Got it?
So I think if you're really ambitious,
seven people can really do
some serious fucking damage
if you do media person,
if you do video, collecting the video,
postproduction, copy, copy matters,
influencer, organic
distribution, biz devving deals.
You could DM, you could message
700 Facebook pages a day
and ask them to distribute your content.
People need content.
They're getting pre-roll ads,
you're getting exposure.
They think they're tricking you
'cause you're giving them
content for their bullshit,
inspire, inspire, inspire.com page.
You're pumped 'cause
you're getting the brand.
They're getting pennies
from the impressions.
You're getting long term dollars.
You could.
That's a 15 hour day job,
business development and distribution.
It could also be seven
people's 15 days jobs.
You'll have 4,000 websites instead of 40.
When there's a moment, you strike.
There is a moment in
communication right now
that I think is worth striking.
That's what this has
all been about with me.
Because if there's a downside
of social media consumption
before voice escalates,
there may be just a
middle window just like,
2014 was a middle window for me.
2013, '12, I'm trying
to remember what it was.
Google was saturated, was
appropriate, search, whatever,
social was organic but
not all the way there yet.
Facebook didn't have its ad product.
There wasn't any crazy good deal.
It's kind of like the economy is now.
Not buying businesses 'cause
they're all overpriced.
It's too frothy, too
much money in the system,
supply and demand.
Good time to sell your brands.
A lot of people in your positions
will be upset that they didn't sell their,
there's somebody right now turning down
a $29 million deal from Kellogg's
because she's like,
well my popcorn brand's
gonna be $100 million
and then the world collapses and it's not.
Or wake the fuck up
and disproportionately
move their allocations
to Amazon and direct-to-consumer.
It's all timing.
That's what you're asking.
All these questions are timing.
To me, it's what makes my game so good
is it's forever.
So when you're playing a game
where you could give up 30
points in the third quarter
and that's okay,
but if you're holding
your breath for an exit,
then it's anxiousness.
But it shouldn't be
predicated on we don't know,
you do know.
Not a lot of people
that know how to sell a
dollar on the internet,
let alone a million dollars.
You do know.
You know something else, the real thing.
Cool.
- [Male] On that selling note,
so I've got a customer,
actually my biggest customer
is a subscription box company
that just destroys it with my products.
So they approached me about helping them
develop their own product line.
I kind of flipped it around and said,
I'm here for you, no problem
but if you guys want to
invest in what I'm wealthy,
take ownership or just
have investment in it,
and we're kind of at a standstill
of they're trying to make the
decision on which way to go--
- They have the leverage.
- [Male] 100%.
- So I think what you did was smart.
- [Male] Okay.
- A lot of big companies
will make private label
versions of their product
for Walmart 'cause they have the leverage.
Depends on how big the box is.
- [Male] It's big.
- More than 30% of your business?
- [Male] Yeah.
- You better make a deal.
- Playing chicken with somebody
who owns a big piece of your business is--
- [Male] I'm not trying to play--
- I can tell, I can tell.
I was waiting for you
and I was gonna kill you
but I was like, oh no, he was smart.
No, no, it was really.
I was waiting.
I was like, oh yeah.
No, no, no, you nailed it.
- [Male] But even if
they come to me and say,
"Listen, we want your help creating--"
- You're gonna be in.
- [Male] That's the right thing to do.
- It's the right thing for your business.
Whoever's closest to the
customer always wins.
They're closer to the
customer than you are.
(upbeat music)